[Music]
hey guys I have a great special guest
today Jason Fong who is uh you all know
he's very famous on YouTube and he's a
nephrologist a kidney specialist and
we're gonna we're here to ask her ask a
lot of questions and get a lot of great
updates he wrote two bestsellers one is
the obesity code and the complete guide
to fasting and he wrote a new one I
think it's called the diabetes code
right right I'm just digging through
that it's like incredible information I
want to start just by talking about some
basic things like what is the cause of
obesity I know you talked about that
many times but yeah and it's a really
important question and one that really
gets to the heart of how you treat it so
essentially the cause of obesity is a
hormonal issue and there's different
hormones but the two main ones are
insulin and cortisol to a lesser extent
but the main one is the insulin and a
lot of people get certain of caught on
the minutia but if you looked at it from
a scientific standpoint the only thing
you need to know is that if insulin is
what causes weight gain then we should
be able to give people insulin and make
them gain weight and it turns out that's
exactly what happens so whenever we
prescribe insulin people gain weight if
people have an insulinoma which is a a
tumor that secretes too much insulin
they gain weight if you give medications
that raise insulin such as so far non
ureas they gain weight when you the
other part of the sort of causal
relationship is that if you take away
insulin they should lose weight so again
this is exactly what you see so in type
1 diabetes for example where you don't
produce any insulin you lose weight when
people type 1 diabetics are taking
insulin and they want to lose weight
there's something called diet bulimia
where they actually stopped taking their
insulin and they lose weight if you keep
taking one of the newer medications
called the sglt2 they also make insulin
go down and you lose weight so every
time you
you came late every time you lower than
you gain weight you can do the same
exercise for cortisol but it tends not
to be as important so again you can get
prednisone and make people gain weight
you can take away prednisone such as the
disease called Addison's disease and
people will lose weight so you know that
there's a causal relationship here so if
insulin is the main problem then you
need to focus on lowering insulin
because if insulin it makes you gain
weight you need to lower insulin
the problem is that we don't focus on
that we focus on calories instead and
there's an overlap so the confusion lies
in that most foods are a combination of
carbohydrates fats and proteins so very
few foods are pure one thing or the
other except for refined carbohydrates
where you can eat things that are almost
pure carbohydrate but for example when
you eat steak for it's a combination of
fat and protein most meals which have a
combination of all three so there is an
overlap between sort of how many
calories you eat and their caloric and
their insulin effect but what it simply
means is that not all foods are equally
fattening which is sort of just common
sense because the sort of lie that we've
been sold
is that all calories are equally
fattening so you can eat kale or you can
eat cookies and they're the same so you
can eat cookies for dinner and skip your
salad and you'll be fine and any idiot
would sort of know that you won't be
fine if you eat cookies for dinner and
that's the real that's the real thing so
when you look at it from a real
scientific standpoint a lot of what we
think about weight gain just doesn't
make any sense that is to say if
calories are so important why doesn't
your body have any sort of mechanism to
measure calories it really has no clue
how many calories you're eating if
you're to reduce calories like for low
fat diets because dietary fat is sort of
the highest in calories so if you reduce
dietary fat you reduce calories you
should be able to lose weight well guess
what
millions of people have done low-calorie
low-fat diets over the last 50 years and
guess what the failure rates somewhere
on the order of 99 percent if we know
that a low-fat low-calorie diet fails 99
percent of the time why on earth would
we recommend it it's absolutely
ridiculous
it's insane so that's what the obesity
code is really about it's about sort of
saying what causes obesity because
that's the most important thing you need
to know if it's too much insulin then
lower insulin how are you going to do
that well you can reduce the
carbohydrate the refined carbohydrates
in your diet you can sort of moderate
protein and eat more of the natural fats
the other thing you can do is
intermittent fasting where you don't eat
for a period of time because the the
fastest way to lower insulin is to eat 0
which is fasting and there's really
nothing intrinsically wrong with that
but again we get into this idea where
people think that oh you need to eat 10
times a day it's like you need to eat 10
times a day to lose weight really how is
that gonna work I was eating more
frequently going to make you lose weight
that doesn't even make any sense
it sounds really stupid because it is
really stupid it's honestly like saying
you should you know roll in the dirt ten
times a day to clean you shouldn't
exactly eat so every time you eat
insulin goes off again assuming that you
eat a mix of macronutrient so every time
you eat is then goes up and that's what
it's supposed to do that's a natural
reaction the insulin goes up and tells
our body to store some of that food
energy when you don't eat like when you
go to sleep at night and when you go to
sleep it's then false and that's a
signal but you should take some of this
food energy that you stored and pull it
back out so you can burn it so there's a
balance there when you eat you store
food energy when you don't eat you burn
food energy balance the two and you
won't gain weight
so if you eat all the time you're
telling your body through insulin to
keep storing food energy and that is not
going to make you lose weight it's gonna
make you gain weight and that's in fact
what exactly what we see so from 1977 to
2004 for example we went from people
eating three meals a day on average to
about six meals a day the most recent
studies looking at people suggest that
they eat for about 14 to 15 hours of the
day and it tends to be shifted later so
if you eat at 8:00 a.m. breakfast for
example you don't stop eating until
about 10:45 p.m. essentially the entire
day you're eating as opposed to 1977
where you eat breakfast lunch dinner
that's it no slack between no bad time
snacks that's it you're eating sort of
ten hours and fast and fourteen hours
instead of sort of the reverse and this
is the thing we're not giving our bodies
the time it needs to burn off this food
energy that we've stored and right
there's nothing more complicated than
that so if you want to lose weight one
don't eat the highest end foods and to
give your body a chance to not eat so
that your insulin levels can fall and
you can burn it exactly so so we have
this mainstream viewpoint that we must
lower sugar despite how much instantly
give you what from your viewpoint high
levels of insulin is even is it possibly
more damaging than high levels of sugar
in the blood I think both are very
important so the thing is so now we're
talking about diabetes where you have
high blood sugar so in type 1 diabetes
insulin levels are low so if that's the
case then giving insulin is a reasonable
thing to do and we know that if you
leave blood sugar levels very high
remember this is type 1 where insulin
levels are low so you're not having any
problem with instances and there's no
but your glucose levels blood glucose
levels are high that that is a
problem so you need to get that down
that's the sort of paradigm of
gluco toxicity that is if you have high
glucose in your blood it's gonna cause
damage what we haven't recognized is
that if you have high insulin levels in
your blood it's also very damaging so in
type 2 diabetes it's a completely
different situation where you have high
insulin levels and high glucose levels
so both are bad but if you simply take
more insulin to to lower your blood
glucose you're just trading toxicities
that is you're taking more insulin so
you're having more damage from the
insulin but your glucose is batters
you're having less damage from the
glucose so more insulin toxicity and
less luke logic to city in the end it's
a wash so you're not actually any
healthier and that's all the studies
that we actually prove this exact point
10 years ago so 10 years we're still
doing the same thing even after there
was the Accord study the Advanced Study
the PABT the Ticos like tons of trials
that have shown that taking more
medications to lower your blood glucose
doesn't make you healthier and that's
the whole point
because if your insulin levels are high
anyway why would you take more it
doesn't make any sense you should in
fact lower them and that would be the
proper treatment because again if you
have hyperthyroidism like if your
thyroid is overactive you don't give
people more thyroid medication right
right it's oh you give it a fire in my
case if it's high you don't do the same
thing so if your insulin levels are low
give insulin if your insulin levels are
high lower it what I did was we gave
more right easy
and then and then so there's kind of an
omission here like traditional medicine
does not necessarily jump in test
fasting insulin levels do fasting
insulin levels are quite variable and
that's that's one of the problems so it
fluctuates quite a bit and in the late
stages of type 2 diabetes sometimes you
see sort of a tapering off of the high
insulin levels are still high but not as
high as it might
back it is I think that what has been
unrecognized is the sort of problem of
too much insulin so obesity is a problem
of too much insulin but type-2 diabetes
also is a problem of too much insulin
that's sort of unrecognized so getting
the fasting insulin that well I do that
regularly to make sure I'm not treating
a situation of type where I think it's
type-2 diabetes but it's actually a
situation of type 1 diabetes where
insulin levels are quite low because
again it's it's you have to know what
you're treating because you can't treat
them to the same you can't treat no
thyroid and high five ride with the same
treatment it doesn't it's like saying
you know washer and the dryer like one
makes her wet and one makes it dry right
but totally different right they the
same thing exactly was there a point in
your career where you um had this huge
shift of like wow we're doing this
backwards what's this like this aha
moment when you about ten years ago so
those studies came out so I was trained
quite conventionally and ten years ago
the conventional thinking in type 2
diabetes so I'm a kidney specialist I
deal with a lot of kidney disease the
most common cause of which is type 2
diabetes sort of by far in a way so I
see a lot of type 2 diabetes patients
and the classical teaching was that you
give as much medication as you need to
get that blood glucose down because the
only thing that's important is that
blood glucose and so that's what I did I
gave people lots of insulin and there
but he posed as Louis I humanly could
the point was in 2008 when all those
trials came out that said that hey
giving lots of insulin to get the blood
glucose down doesn't actually make
people healthier man that was when I
started thinking wow that's a total
change of everything that we had been
taught like everything everything
changed
but unfortunately sort of what happened
was that the specialist and the
our cities they just kept teaching the
same thing you have as much medication
as you need to get the blood glucose
down and I kept thinking well isn't that
exactly what we proved to be untrue and
it was very strange to watch this I'm
but the problem is that people were so
deep into this paradigm of just get the
blood glucose down that they never
stopped to think about what could what
was the problem and that was when I
really started thinking well there's
another problem too and the patient's my
patients had recognized that long before
I recognized that so you got to
recognize that type-2 diabetes is a
reversible disease okay so if you lose
weight the diabetes type 2 diabetes
almost always goes away if you just look
at studies of bariatric surgery for
example where people get their stomachs
caught and so on and in this way the
diabetes almost always resolves like in
90% of cases unless the weight comes
back so we know if they lose weight the
diabetes goes away when we prescribe
insulin to these type 2 diabetics who
are older and overweight generally they
tend to gain with it so it's like okay
the patients would always say look
doctor you always tell me that I need to
lose weight then you give me insulin and
I gain like 40 pounds well how is that
making my diabetes better and I didn't
have a good answer because the answer
was that it wasn't making that better
but the point is that type-2 diabetes is
really a disease of too much sugar in
your body when you take a medication
such as insulin it actually forces that
sugar into the bottom remember insulin
is what the hormone that tells your body
to store that food energy so if your
sugar is high you take insulin your
body's gonna store it it's gonna turn it
into fat so of course they gain weight
but the question is what does it do to
the sugar has it gotten rid of that
excess sugar in your body the answer is
no it simply forced it into your body
where you can't see it because it's not
in the blood anymore but the sugar goes
all over your body it goes into your
heart and your liver and your kidneys
and over 10-15 years
all your organs basically just brought
away that's my diabetics have disease of
everything so if you take a disease such
as a osteomyelitis or gangrene for
example those are diseases that are
seeing virtually in no other case other
than that it's type 2 diabetes the
question is why why do you get this
osteomyelitis infection of the bone
which is very rare elsewhere are you
getting mucormycosis which are these
rare fungal infections because you've
got way too much sugar all over the
place and the bacteria love them so
they're just happy to proliferate and
then you get a bad infection so the
point is that if you take insulin you're
not getting rid of the sugar you're
simply moving it into your body and
eventually if you stop taking the
insulin all that sugar just comes back
out in the blood so you've really done
nothing for this disease and that was
the answer to why the sort of current
paradigm of sort of diabetes treatment
was completely wrong if you don't if
people are not losing weight the
diabetes is not going to get better so
that's where I became very interested in
the question of what causes weight gain
and it turns out it was the same answer
and that's why they related to both
diseases of too much insulin but it's
very powerful because once you know that
these are diseases of too much insulin
the solution is obvious know where
insulin right on you that no
carbohydrate diets intermittent fasting
don't lower calories because when you
lower calories you may or may not lower
insulin you could take diet coke for
example zero calories does anybody lose
weight drinking diet coke not really
right we've been drinking it for 50
years it's a it's one of the top sort of
three soda pops in the world and clearly
there's less calories than a regular
coke but it doesn't cause less obesity
so we know that it's it's not the
calories calories is not the right thing
that we should be focusing on so so you
being a kidney spell a specialist you
you'd probably see a lot of patients
coming with stage-four on kidney
dialysis and advanced stages what has
been your experience with working with
some of those guys do some of them not
need dialysis anymore once we get to
that stage it's often too late and I had
hoped when I started that yes maybe some
of them could reverse you can reverse in
the very early stages we'll keep in mind
that diabetic kidney disease often takes
15 to 20 years to manifest so if you're
coming in at the 18th year very often it
will make no difference
so you can reverse it when when you
catch it early but we catch it late it's
hard it's like if you were not to change
the oil in your car and then it breaks
down and say oh now I'm gonna chase you
on my car it's like oh great but it's
not gonna do anything for your car
that's broken down it's the same idea
once all that damage is sustained it's
really very difficult to get it to
reverse it because you've taken that
that hit already so that's why I'm
focused more on getting the message out
and getting letting people know that hey
type 2 diabetes is not an irreversible
disease it's a reversible disease it's a
dietary disease focus on your diet if
you reverse diabetic disease you're not
going to get the diabetic problems that
you'll get later on but if they've
developed already it's very hard to
reverse that it's still worthwhile to
work with them because there's they're
at high risk of other problems but that
kidney disease very often doesn't
reverse what about when a patient
develops a problem to the point where
their potassium starts going higher and
higher and so then they go the doctor
and the doctor says avoid all potassium
foods including vegetables and is there
have you found that they pretty much
need to avoid the supplement potassium
or do they have to avoid also vegetables
in general because it's high in
potassium is that the Baals need to be
avoided so again this is in the
relatively unusual situation where
you're talking about
advanced kidney disease and there's sort
of nuances in that
the kidneys are not working they're not
getting rid of the potassium so if you
take foods like avocado which are quite
high in potassium then your body's not
going to be able to get rid of it so you
do have to be careful for certain types
of foods that are high in potassium
bananas for example your oranges mangoes
so there's a number of things that are
high in potassium so but that is a
fairly unusual situation in you know
overall so it's a but but yes if your
get to that stage you do have to be a
little bit careful
that's why intermittent fasting works
because even if you're worried about
high phosphorus high potassium as
advanced kidney disease because you're
actually eating zero you don't have to
worry about that your potassium intake
is going to be lower than if you're to
eat and again this is you know that for
us we've we've sort of pioneered this
sort of the therapeutic use of fasting
so we have a program called the
intensive dietary management program
where we help people with the fossum
because it's not fun it's not easy right
it's healthy but it's it's hard it's
hard work and that's what we need people
to do is get the support they need and
that's what we provide in our intensive
dietary management program to people but
there are certain sort of medical things
if you have advanced disease you do have
to be a little bit careful in terms of
the fasting interferon medications yeah
be careful in that sort of thing young
guys if I'm gonna put a link down below
- he has not only books he has a program
on his website we'll put a link down
below check it out
I've heard great results from what
you're doing and you're in Canada so you
can actually you don't have to be in
Canada you can be anywhere in the world
and sent to his program and coaching or
get the data because you have videos in
there you have all sorts of educational
stuff yeah so there's tons of stuff so
there's a ton of free stuff on there I
write a weekly blog and there's links to
let you tube videos and so on so there's
tons of free stuff and then if
you if you need more than we also have a
sort of a membership community where we
do the group fasts and so on and then if
you want more you get sort of small
group coaching so with somebody who's
sort of experienced with the fasting and
can help you because there are problems
that do come up there are things such as
headaches and motivation is a big one so
doing things in a group is just a lot
easier than doing stuff yourself and
also if you have somebody to talk to so
we have forums that people can
communicate with each other and those
are the sort of things that make it easy
so it's interesting to me because people
always they all never do that but you're
gonna recognize that many religions have
prescribed periods of fasting so if you
look at Catholicism during Lent for
example if you look at Ramadan and the
Muslim faith if you look at Buddhist for
example Hindus Mormons almost any
religion the reason is a lot easier for
them is because they're all doing it as
a group so if you're doing a month of
fasting or it's Lent then you're
supposed to fasts or you've heard of
Greek Orthodox Church well all your
friends and family are fasting too so
one if you have any problems they can
help you like you know they can make
sure you're staying well hydrated and
all this sort of stuff but they're not
like cooking a big meal in front of you
while you're supposed to thousand
everybody's doing it together so it's
just a lot easier so that's the sort of
group support that is actually very very
important in any type of behavioural
change and we know that from groups such
as say Weight Watchers which their diet
is okay but the secret sauce if you will
is the root support same as Alcoholics
Anonymous they know very well what you
have to do abstain from alcohol not that
difficult but the secret sauce is that
group support that they get from each
other and I don't know why we don't
provide it for each other but because
fasting is relatively new and people
there's still a lot of myths and
misconceptions around the fact that oh
you have to eat
times a day and so on people don't get
the help that they need in order to be
successful and there's other things like
you know people for example to help with
this hunger and so on so you can use T
for example green tea which has this
thing called the catagen which is that
they have antioxidants but they have
this thing called catechins and it's
been shown that there's a small appetite
suppressing effect as well with
something as simple as green tea which
you can buy anywhere or there's a
fasting tea for example which is a
special cold brewed tea that you can use
and it may help with the hunger for
example so these sort of things which
are simple and relatively inexpensive
can help people but you're not going to
know about it unless you sort of are
talking to people about and because it's
so new it's hard for people and that's
what we're trying to provide it's sort
of support for the fasting but there's
also free groups like Facebook groups
and so on there's there's there's a ton
of information out there if you dig a
little bit you're probably in you know
if you put a little work into it you
could probably find all the information
for free it's all out there everything
is out there for free these days right
yeah yeah specially on YouTube so the
benefits of fasting go beyond weight
loss right yeah so there's a lot of very
interesting sort of benefits to fasting
and one the most obvious of course is
weight loss and also treatment of type 2
diabetes so we do it a lot to her first
time to diabetes and again not very
difficult if you don't eat your blood
sugars will come down because your body
is burning it off if electric is coming
down you don't need to take your
medications so we reverse a lot of
people's type 2 diabetes but beyond that
there's other benefits so people find
for example that their concentration
improves they're able to do more because
their their mental abilities name proof
with that and people think oh that's
strange because I thought it was the
opposite it's like well it's not think
about a time where you eat a huge meal
like Thanksgiving
were you really really mentally sharp or
where you just sort of slide in front of
the TV watching football
well it's probably the latter people who
who don't eat actually may have
increased mental abilities because you
have to understand that when insulin
Falls like when you fast insulin Falls
but other hormones go up these are the
so-called counter regulatory hormones
and two important ones one is more
adrenaline so it actually increases the
amount of energy that goes into your
system so if you look at your metabolic
rate everybody says well you're gonna go
into starvation mode that's not what
happens because as your noradrenaline
goes up your metabolic rate does
maintain so if you measure the amount of
calories somebody is burning at the
start of a four day five so after four
days of not eating they're actually
burning 10% more calories than when they
started
and it's because of this counter
regulatory hormones you're changing the
hormone so that you're actually flooding
your body with energy the reason is that
this is a survival mechanism so if you
think back to cavemen days pose you're a
caveman and you don't eat for a few days
if you've got weaker and mentally dulled
well you would really never eat again
because it's a spiral right you don't
eat you get a little weaker a little bit
you know less mentally sharp which means
you're less able to get food and so it's
even harder to get food so you go
another day and that's worse and worse
and worse you spiral down and you die
then we wouldn't be sitting here today
so it's instead of that then mother
nature is just not that stupid right
instead of that what it does is our body
doesn't shut down it actually switches
fuel sources from food to body fat and
pumps us up full of energy so
noradrenaline goes up and growth hormone
goes up into the other hormone we're
going to talk about and when you do that
you increase your mental abilities then
you increase your energy so that you can
go out and hunt and get some food to eat
so people have done studies for example
on memory and it increases with fasting
and people have done
you know have talked about it so what
was really interesting to me is when I
was reading a biography of this prisoner
of war in Japan and American prisoner
war and they're literally starving like
they have almost nothing to eat and he
describes these incredible mental feats
he says you know other prisoners were
learned Norwegian in like four days and
look entirely from his mind and the
credible mental feats and he goes well
it's just the astonishing mental clarity
of starvation Wow look they actually
wrote that oh maybe who actually went
through severe severe starvation because
that's what it was and he's pretty good
and these prisoner of war camps
understood that people got so smart
doing this it was just like yeah I see
it every day like you know this guy's
doing this and this and it's incredible
and this is one of the reasons that the
intermittent fasting has taken off in
Silicon Valley it's like the hottest
diet trend because like these are not
people trying to lose weight they're
these computer geniuses but they're
competing against other computer
geniuses and if you're a little bit
smarter that's the difference between
being Facebook and being myspace right
you could either be a billionaire or you
could be nothing right for that extra
little mental edge this huge and if you
can do it while doing something healthy
and doing something free and basically
hacking yourself into that extra mental
edge okay it could mean a lot right it's
just like performance athletics that
last little bit is this is so important
so that mental ability is one of the
benefits the increased energy is one of
the benefits and we hear it all the time
people coming in and they're saying oh
wow I have so much energy lady we had we
couldn't barely go from the waiting room
to my office like we be basically the
next time which is like right
it was crazy because she was on all this
insulin and remember insulin which goes
up when you eat is the storage hormone
it tells you about to store the energy
so if you're taking a ton of insulin
your body is busy storing all this
energy and you're not able to use it
because it's all going into storage so
when we took her off we allowed her
insulin to go low which allowed her body
to start releasing these energy stores
remember it's not that you're shutting
down your body you're switching your
fuel sources from food to body fat it's
like that's perfect does it slackly what
we want to happen and then there's more
theoretical benefits so for example
Alzheimer's disease some people have
thought that intermittent fasting may be
very beneficial because you stimulate
this other sort of cellular cleaning
process called ecology so when you
particularly when you're doing water
fasts get past a certain sort of 24 to
36 hours you stimulate a process called
a tapa G which is where your body
actually breaks down protein so you
break down these subsets of parts which
tend to be the older parts that aren't
working so well and everybody thinks wow
break down a protein that's really bad
it's not really bad because the other
hormone that goes up quite a bit it's
growth hormone so when you do a sort of
aged feeding fasting cycle as you fast
you're going to break down some protein
but as you start to eat again because
growth hormone is way up you're actually
going to rebuild that protein so it's a
whole sort of renewal process so it's
just like renovating your bathroom for
example the first thing you know to do
is actually throw out that lime green
tub from the seventies right if you
don't take that out you can't put a new
one in - the first step is to actually
break it down then rebuild it and that
actually keeps you functioning better
than if you never broke it down in the
first place which is why a lot of people
consider the fasting which used to be
called sort of a
same thing which is what it is you're
cleaning out that old stuff in your body
and you're trying to renew it with new
stuff which is like perfect because it's
a free process and it's a process that's
been used for thousands of years not as
something which is like oh I'm going to
punish you it was used because people
knew that it was sort of intrinsically
healthy for for staying well and all
this sort of thing so it's a fascinating
science sort of modern science this just
sort of catching up to this sort of 2000
year old idea but once in a while we
should fast right whether it's the
Prophet Muhammad with Ramadan or if it's
Jesus Christ with Lent and all that
we're just catching up to this idea that
hey these guys they didn't know the
science but they knew that when people
did this they actually stayed relatively
healthy because remember there's no
obesity 2,000 years ago or that's very
little but it's something that's healthy
and hey now we're realizing yeah it can
be healthy and even for things like
cancer well same thing cancer is a
disease of increased growth so if you
fast you're going to shut down these
growth pathways so everybody thinks you
know cancer is a genetic disease but in
fact there's a lot more to it than that
because the World Health Organization
categorizes at 11 or 14 cancers as
obesity related including common ones
like breast cancer and colorectal cancer
and so on so if you allow instant to
fall you're not going to have these
growth signals which is going to
possibly prevent a lot of these sort of
obesity related cancers from gaining
hope that's theoretical but makes a lot
of sense these days absolutely what type
of fasting do you do personally I took
that please stick to sort of 24-hour
fast and that's because the are sort of
number one rule for fasting is to fit it
into your lifestyle so if you do
something very intrusive on
lifestyle you can do it but not for very
long it's it's a therapy right it's
therapeutic okay so I had one time one
fellow who used to fast and so he used
to get together with his friends every
so often to you know to meet a chat and
he'd stop doing that because it's like
them and that's not the point the point
is to fit it in where you can but do
everything you normally do because again
having friends is very important I mean
get it going out and celebrating is very
important so you have to find something
that you're going to be able to stick to
so doing something like a 3 or 5 day
fast is very intrusive because if I
don't do it like I usually have dinner
with my family most nights so I can do
that but it's hard if you're fasting
everybody's eating you're not you it's
hard so that to me works the best a lot
of 24-hour fast and once in a while out
throwing it longer fast so three days or
longer and that's typically after I go
on vacation and on vacation I typically
don't fast because again I'm with my
family most of the time and you know
they want to eat or and we'll go out
I'll still you know trying to limit
stuff but on the other hand you don't
want to be the party pooper all the time
right you know you know I won't do
anything go out and all this sort of
stuff it's not it's there's no balance
there so you gotta find what works for
you and for some people it's longer fast
I'm for sure too fast but that's the
sort of thing I stick to when my pants
start to get a little tight then I do my
best right really busy then I do more
fast thing when I decide to like during
holiday so typically all do Christmas
for example I won't I won't watch when I
at all and I will probably do very
little fasting and also during vacation
and I've made that decision but I know
that I have to make up for it afterwards
so right you know I just I just went on
vacation and I had a lot to eat and I
felt great and then I got back and my
pants were a little tight and I up the
fasting so I'll typically do it at least
twice a week
the last couple of weeks I've been doing
it for five times a week and now my
pants get better now so did you find
before you started fasting that were you
the grazer that snack between meals and
at night you were you that touch person
not typically but I think that we had
all sort of started becoming that so if
you look at meetings and so on right so
you go to a meeting I don't know if you
do a lot of meeting for like at the
hospital or any company and you have a
meeting at 10:00 a and then there's
muffins and you go for lunch meeting
there's lunch and then you go for an
afternoon meeting and there's more
muffins or Donuts or cookies or
something and the problem is that when
they're there it's extremely tempting
and that's something that's new it's
like that's something that we don't need
we got fine
by fine in the 60s and 70s without sort
of muffins and bagels at 10:00 a.m.
meeting so why do we need it now and so
we had all sort of become that sort of
oh we should eat something and and it's
the same it's become ingrained in our
society and I think it's very unhealthy
so my son went to camp this week and you
know they send me back an email saying
oh welcome to camp we're going to
provide lunch and two snacks why do all
these kids need snack kids but you go
play soccer for example so the kids used
to play soccer and at every halftime
somebody thought it was necessary that
the kids have some juice and cookies why
I used to go out in play soccer as did
everybody else in the 1970s and guess
what nobody ate snacks my parents
weren't chasing me around with a juice
box and two cookies I'll tell you that
much you just went out and played and
had a great time you didn't even think
twice about whether you wanted to eat
because you're too busy playing yeah I
mean your parent your parents would sit
down all of us would sit down three
meals but then now it's like everyone's
on the run grab
quick food no one eats it's down it's
like it's completely shifted the whole
lifestyle shifted to small snacks bring
snack between meals after school the
whole thing exactly and and there's
nothing wrong I mean we're not going to
change the fact that people are gonna be
on the run all the time but changing the
sort of snacking habit and making sure
that you have a proper fast because we
remember a very word breakfast means you
have to fast it's a meal that breaks
you're fast if you're not fasting you
can't break it so therefore you should
be like 10 or 12 hours like you
shouldn't finish dinner and then not eat
anything until breakfast there's no need
for for it for an evening snack that
just isn't and you don't need to have
that so even if you are on the run
because you're going to this and I'm it
this that you can still eat three meals
a day and not snack but there has to be
this recognition that hey snacking is
actually pretty pretty fattening which
is probably what your grandmother would
have told you now we've gone from Oh
snacking is fattening to snacking is
super healthy that's why we're ordering
muffins for our meeting it's like no we
should get rid of that you can have
coffee but don't have don't order the
plate of muffins don't order the plate
of cookies don't order anything you've
gone to medical conferences they're the
worst
even the obesity conferences we go there
what do you get you get breakfast at
10:30 you come out and there's a full
spread of banana loaf sand mock mint
cookies then it's like yeah because you
only ate breakfast like an hour and a
half ago and you're going to teach in an
hour and a half like obviously you need
a muffin in between right it's like come
on then you have your your your lunch
and then and then at 2:30 at the the
afternoon break guess what another full
spread every single medical conference
is the same right oh my god oh my god
it's like terrible but again when it
gets when you see it over and over again
and when you're exposed to it in your
school you think that it's normal and
you think that that's healthy it's not
it's completely new to this sort of
generation and guess what they're not
better for it incredible Wow well thank
you so much for your time and your input
this data was extremely valuable people
are going to get a lot of it and hey
guys I'm gonna put some links down below
check out his website his programs his
books it's extremely valuable well thank
you so much doc and we'll talk to you
soon
all right thanks Eric